Bergen iron Heights guidelines best team
the league runs the town hall okay go go
ahead Josh
it's record
there have been some complaints that
this season has been weird two XFL
quarterbacks are starting you know Smith
is a star and people are actually
enjoying themselves in the New York
section
[Applause]
I'll now open the meeting up to concerns
we need a town curfew I'm thinking like
4 30. wait I have to wear a helmet after
my ride is over hey everyone recycle
your quarterbacks it's not that hard I
don't like how suddenly we're all waking
up with aches and pains and how we all
thought we could outrun father time
forever but now he draws ever closer
with each tick of the game clock expand
the rushing Lanes I'm not here to make
excuses I wrote them all down before I
got here okay unless there's any other
kick me out well I've got all your pets
and I'm gonna this is just a normally
scheduled town hall meeting oh well then
I guess I'll just sell these back to you
then
why should I have to direct traffic
people should just know where to go we
shouldn't have to work when it's spooky
season if other QBs are better then why
don't they debate me there's just a lot
of pressure to be as awful as the guy
who had my position before me and
another thing it is [ __ ] that the
Rogers rate isn't real